ja mein Thema greift vieles von dem auf
was wir gerade diskutiert haben ich will
es auf zwei Punkte reduzieren einmal das
was ich nennen würde die Politik der
Angst und zum Anderen eben
geschwindende Attraktivität von
Demokratie in unserer Gesellschaft mit
Politik der Angst bezeichne ich etwas
was jeder sehr sehr gut kennt in den
letzten Jahren nicht geschlafen hat das
ist nämlich die schlicht Tatsache dass
wir von einem panikmodus in den anderen
verfallen und auch getrieben werden das
beginnt schon mit der migrationskrise
oder auch schon mit der Schuldenkrise
von Griechenland geht dann über in die
corona-krise natürlich die sogenannte
Klimakatastrophe und jetzt der drohende
Atomkrieg in Ukraine also im Grunde gibt
es kaum mal ein verschnaufen zwischen
den verschiedenen Panik Anlässen man
könnte jetzt einerseits sagen ja so ist
die Welt es ist schrecklich und
natürlich entspricht dem ja auch etwas
in der Wirklichkeit aber ich glaube das
wirklich gefährliche ist dass es sehr
viele Politiker gibt die das Ausnutzen
also die Tatsache dass wir so leicht in
Panik zu versetzen sind den Menschen die
in Panik versetzt sind denen kann man
fast alles oktrohieren den kann man fast
alles zuboten und ich glaube es gibt so
eine Art Versuchung in Richtung
Despotismus in unserer Politik und das
ist natürlich die drastischste
Aushebelung von Demokratie die man sich
vorstellen kann und dazu passt leider
Gottes eben auch und damit sind wir bei
ihrem oder unserem bisherigen Thema dazu
passt eben auch sehr sehr gut dass viele
Aktivisten nicht nur in ihrem Gebiet
sondern in allen anderen Bereichen auch
im Grunde versuchen die das narrativ ja
zu platzieren also die Geschichte zu
erzählen mit demokratischen Mitteln
lassen sich die dringenden Probleme
unserer Zeit nicht mehr lösen man sagt
das so drastisch nicht obwohl man wenn
man Frau Neubauer beispielsweise zuhört
man das schon deutlich heraushören kann
aber im Grunde ist das der gemeinsame
Nenner sehr sehr vieler Positionen und
Statements und das ist die größte Gefahr
die wir meines Erachtens heute haben das
größte Gefahr ist nicht die
Klimakatastrophe die größte Gefäß ist
nicht die Migrationswelle oder auch
Pandemie und Corona die größte Gefahr
ist dass wir unser rechtsstaatliches
Fundament aufs Spiel setzen weil wir uns
in Panik versetzen lassen und das sind
leider Gottes die Medien nicht ganz
unschuldig bildhaft TV natürlich macht
alles wieder gut aber
auch kräftig mit bei diesem panikmodus
in denen die Politik und so nein führen
will und es gibt Leute die es darauf
gerade zu spezialisiert sind auch in der
Regierung man muss nur an Lauterbach
denken also das halte ich für ein
Riesenproblem und den letztlich geht es
auch darauf zurück dass man und da ist
die Klimabewegung die Klima der
klimaaktivismus natürlich
hauptverantwortlich dass wir uns daran
gewöhnen sollten offensichtlich alles im
Sinn von drohende Katastrophen zu sehen
es ist nicht nur fünf vor zwölf ich
glaube die Weltuhr Weltkatastrophen oder
die von irgendwelchen at kann immer
wieder gestellt wird ist nur noch wenige
Sekunden vor zwölf einige sagen schon
ist schon nach 12 also man will uns im
Grunde sagen und das ist das
entscheidende wir haben keine Zeit mehr
zum Diskutieren und letztlich auch keine
Zeit mehr zum Nachdenken wir müssen
jetzt handeln und zwar müssen wir
handeln so wie die Aktivisten sich das
vorstellen wenn ich das einmal
zusammenfassen darf sie sagen also die
Politik schürt bewusst die Ängste um die
Bürger besser zu kontrollieren richtig
wobei ich nicht sage es gäbe gar keinen
Grund für Angst es gibt Grund Angst zu
haben vor Putin es gibt Grund Angst
haben dafür dass vielleicht der
Meeresspiegel Spiegel tatsächlich
aber dass man daraus ein Panik Thema
macht und den Leuten im Grunde
suggeriert das Thema ist so präsent so
dringend dass es weder technische
Möglichkeiten gibt das noch zu
bewältigen noch in irgendeiner Weise auf
demokratische abstimmungs-
zwar in den radikalsten Formen die
gerade von den Aktivisten vorgeschlagen
hat das ist für mich die eigentliche
Gefahr habe ich da einmal ganz kurz
einen Haken ich finde es nämlich
interessant weil er auf eine gewisse Art
und Weise gebe ich Ihnen Recht dass wir
auch als Klima gerechtigkeitsbewegung
vielleicht tatsächlich zu sehr in die
Zukunft die ganze Zeit projizieren zu
sagen der Klimawandel kommt das eine
drohende Katastrophe wie wir uns jetzt
erst was machen gegen eine
ich mache einmal ganz kurz den Punkt
fertig weil wenn wir nämlich darauf
zurückkommen zu gucken aber was
verursacht den Klimawandel dann müssen
wir ja eigentlich drauf wir wollen
einmal da muss ich leider bringen wollen
einmal jetzt wirklich gezielt beim Thema
Angst bleiben nicht bei den Ursachen des
Klimawandel ich kann es auch darauf also
ist ja schon eine spannende Frage bei
Ihnen auch oder bei den klimaaktivisten
verspüren Sie denn große Angst weniger
vom Klimawandel als vor der menschlichen
Bedingungen sozusagen die oder
gesellschaftlichen Bedingungen die das
überhaupt möglich aber sie verströmen ja
große Angst vor dem Klima rein also ich
habe jetzt nicht das Gefühl dass wir in
unseren Aktionen die großen die großen
Trommeln die der großen trommelschwingen
und ich glaube das ist tatsächlich auch
etwas wo ich auch propagieren würde zu
sagen lasst uns einmal gucken was jetzt
schon dabei ist zu passieren und das
macht Angst sonst werden Menschen eben
wie die deaktivistin ja auch im Video
gesagt hat gerade jetzt werden Menschen
von ihren Ländern vertrieben gerade
jetzt werden Menschen umgebracht für den
Widerstand den sie leisten für ihren
Lebensunterhalt
ich persönlich ja beides
beides geht zusammen tatsächlich wir
wollen alle Argumente noch in der in der
Runde hören deswegen würde ich gerne
Fragen Herr Stöckel Angst weil etwas
leichter als hier aus du hast jetzt kurz
überlegt ob ich die ob ich seine These
verstanden habe
nein aber wie empfinden Sie die These
ist da etwas dran dass die Politik Panik
und Angst schürt also du weißt ja dass
ich mich wahnsinnig gut immer auf die
Sendungen vorbereite und natürlich mit
die Thesen alle im Vorfeld durchlese und
ich habe mich dann so gefragt naja
stimmt das und wie weit glaube ich dass
das so ist also erstmal glaube ich dass
Schuld nicht nur die Politik hat sondern
ich glaube auch dass es auch und das da
muss ich Ihnen leider recht geben ich
glaube das hat auch viel mit den Medien
zu tun also ich glaube viel Angst wird
eigentlich auch durch die Medien
geschürt und ich will jetzt gar kein
bestimmtes Medium nennen und wirklich
also jetzt ohne ohne Ironie und gar
nichts ich glaube aber das wenn ich
jetzt die Politiker so sehe ich also bei
den meisten eher keine Angst vor spüre
also ich habe jetzt weder vor Frau
bärbock noch vorhin Lindner Angst
irgendwie und ich glaube auch nicht dass
sie mir persönlich Angst machen ich
glaube halt eher dass ich manchmal das
Gefühl habe dass die Medien bestimmte
Themen so hoch pushen das glaube ich die
Leute eher denken okay gut wir sind
jetzt vielleicht doch am Ende der Welt
schon aber ich glaube die Politiker also
mich beängstigt ist nicht so also ich
habe eher Angst vor manchen Kollegen in
meinem Geschäft nämlich beängstigend
ein Volk die man Angst gemacht hat
regiert sich leichter ein ängstliche
Menschen natürlich nach halb nach
Orientierung nach Bindungen suchen
ich habe unabgesprochen er hat ein
tolles Buch geschrieben über aber kann
der Angst ich habe Kapitel geschrieben
über die vorbokratie
Demokratie
also Phobie vor Demokratie Topographie
herrschen mit Angst
Gott schreiben jetzt Moment das machen
wir gleich pädagogisch noch ein bisschen
weiter
ein bisschen weiter warum macht die
Politik das im Schulterschluss mit NGOs
und was der Teufel aus und Medien weil
sie unter einer
demophobie leidet
hemophobie
demophobie
ich darf vom demonstrieren
nein aber okay jetzt top ich seine These
ein Volk
und Flecken
und ein dummes und dumm gemachtes und
dumm gehaltenes Volk jetzt bin ich bei
meinem Lieblingsthema bildungsnationen
so wir geben jetzt eine ganz kurze
Unterbrechung
herrscht